this changes everything because the One
Piece manga just started maybe the most
hyped flashback of all time because for
the very first time ever we learn what
actually took place on the legendary
Island God Valley and wow Oda really
knows how to take everything that we
thought we knew and just you know throw
it right into the trash because this
island is insane and absolutely changes
everything that we thought we knew about
the legendary battle between the former
pirate king gty Roger and the infamous
pirate Rox dbec as well but that is of
course far from the only incredible
reveal in this chapter because on top we
also learned that the celestial dragons
are probably the singlehandedly most
scumback group of characters I have ever
seen in any story and even shank's dad
or uncle or whoever this guy here really
is is just as bad as the rest of them
and then there is the possibility that
we actually just met Luffy's mother huh
and what's probably just as crazy though
is that we finally learned exactly what
is so special about barthol Kuma's race
where Kuma might have gotten his
incredible devil fruit and how his
lineage directly ties back to Sun God
Nika from the distant past oh yeah and
speaking of the past we just saw more of
St Saturn's mindblowing abilities which
are not only super powerful they also
seem to break all sorts of rules that we
thought we knew about one piece and I
honestly have so many questions but also
some answers about his mysterious powers
and so let's actually start with st
Saturn here because he showed off some
truly unbelievable stuff right at the
start of this chapter first he kind of
brushed off having a sword stabbed into
his chest like it was nothing I mean we
already thought that was going to happen
but not only that the blood disappeared
as if nothing had happened at all like
what now we've only seen one devil fruit
in the entire story so far that actually
lets you heal yourself so if Saturn has
some sort of healing powers that
instantly makes him a enormous threat
right out the get-go I kind of have to
wonder though is this ability because of
his demon transformation which again to
be clear we still don't know if this is
actually a devil fruit or if he is truly
just some sort of straightup devil-like
demon-like creature but the fact that
Vega Punk just clearly shouts out that
it must be a devil fruit power makes me
kind of think that it's more likely than
not that he's just straight up a devil
like man I'm getting chills just
thinking about fact that we're finally
getting to see this guy in action but I
do have some sort of idea about a
potential weakness as well which we will
discuss in just a moment so before we
get distracted here Saturn's healing was
just the very first ability that he
showed off here because he then burst
out this evil eye looking sort of power
to damage both Bonnie and Sanji and well
I'm still not too clear what this power
exactly is it does seem like this is
some sort of really special projectile
attack maybe something like an inv
visible hockey bullet or just some kind
of demonic ability but whatever it is it
is insanely powerful because it actually
drew blood from both Bonnie but much
more impressively when you think about
it Sanji which is a massive feat because
remember that sanji's body is now
ridiculously sturdy and Powerful I mean
he literally tanked this massive sword
Blow from kaido's second commander and
even this full force attack from the
overpowered saae without even flin and
so just making Sanji start bleeding just
shows the raw power of even this very
apparently basic attack from Saturn now
at this point I was kind of hoping that
Sanji might actually stand a chance
against Saturn here but I was dead wrong
right out of the gate because just
moments later Saturn somehow manages to
freeze everyone with this mysterious
power once again which is just like wow
like how's he doing all of that because
these are powerful Fighters as well but
they're literally completely helpless
against the Celestial Dragon and now I'm
really wondering can Saturn even be
killed in the first place I mean later
on in this chapter we actually seem to
get even more evidence for the goto say
are Immortal Theory because during the
flashback at God Valley which will of
course break down in just a moment
patience he basically looked completely
unchanged from the time to now which is
40 years ago and I do know that people
in the one piece World usually live a
lot longer than in real life but come on
I mean 30 8 years is quite a long time
to not look any different at all so I do
think we're once again on the side of
yeah the goo say are just straight up
Immortal beings maybe straight from the
void Century which doesn't mean that
they can't be killed though and and
Saturn's comment from the last chapter
about not having come down to the
surface from the red line in a long time
does make me wonder if they don't come
down from marija because of one
particular weakness and that yeah would
of course be the ocean the sea itself
which is basically the enemy of devil
fruit users in the entire world and so
assuming that he has a devil fruit or
that his devil fruit form is also
considered an enemy of the sea forcing
Saturn into the ocean could be the one
save way to kill him I mean it's
certainly possible and after Saturn
straight up told kizaru that he was a
disappointment which oh my God that was
cold I'm really wondering if we could
see the Admiral pick up his boss at some
point and just dump him straight into
the I mean just a theory but with all
the setup of kizaru being a slave I
would love to see him break those chains
and take out St Saturn I've been kind of
on the entire ride of the Admirals
possibly you know turning sides aiji has
already done it we've seen ainu being
very impatient with the Goro and then we
have kizaru who's clearly not a fan of
having to fight all his former friends
so that would be sick to see but
speaking of slaves let's discuss the
mindblowing true nature of God Valley
here now there are three major changes
that we just have to talk about the
first is what is God Valley secondly the
characters involved in this epic and
also incredibly tragic event and the
third is about one particular little
red-haired kit and so let's kick it off
with what even is this place because
ever since chapter 957 when soku
revealed the legendary battle between
the pirate king Goldie Roger and the
infamous pirate Rox dbec that took place
on God Valley I think pretty much
everyone just assumed that God Valley
was some sort of Home Island for the
celestial dragons but nope we were
completely off I mean turns out that
this island was its own independent
Kingdom that just happened to offend the
world government by calling themselves
God and so because of this it was chosen
38 years ago to be the site of a
bloodthirsty tournament where a bunch of
slaves and the people already living on
God Valley are all hunted down like
animals by the world Nobles and I mean
like wow if you didn't already hate the
space suit wearing World Nobles then
surely you will do now but that's not
all that we learned here because
apparently this slave hunting tournament
used to take place every 3 years which
hold on if they have been doing this
ever since the void Century 800 years
ago that would mean that uh they would
have taken out over
254 islands with this kind of sickening
tur tournament not including the last 38
years I mean how is it possible that
they're even that evil and also that
explains why the one piece world is so
much water we've seen the sea level rise
one meter ever since the first island
got taken out the one at lulua so just
imagine that happening 200x times how
much the ocean would have risen since
then how much land would have been
vanished and just in general how many
islands that just straight up don't
exist anymore now of course we don't
know the full story of this yet and I'm
wondering if they stopped this tradition
after the events of God Valley because
we have not heard of this tournament
before and we also know that God Valley
was essentially wiped off the map so
it's possible that what ever happened
here was so awful for the world
government that they decided to never
hold the tournament again Plus St Saturn
was clearly at God Valley but then he
said he hadn't been to the surface in a
long time so maybe this particular
tournament was the actual last time that
he went down on the surface himself now
I just have to know what was that
catastrophic event that made them end
the tournament and we'll discuss more
about that in just a moment but first I
want to talk about the main people who
were absolutely known to be involved in
this event including a confirmed epic
one on this battle that we never ever
knew about in the first place and
starting with the person who seems to be
the main villain of this flashback the
Holy Knight figland Garling now in case
you forgot he is this guy and it now
seems more likely than ever that he is
truly shank's dad because I mean they
just look incredibly similar or if not
his dad maybe shank's uncle or something
like that but apart from killing the
original King Of God Valley Garling is
expected to be the champion of this
slave hunt which we can assume means
that he's clearly the most powerful or
maybe most ruthless of the world Nobles
participating here but now that we know
that his appearance is actually so
similar to shank's it puts a whole new
context on this panel right here from
ages ago because while we never really
thought that Roger actually gave
Whitebeard some heavy scars in battle
it's very possible now that Whitebeard
actually fought against Garling during
the battle on God Valley we do know that
Whitebeard was present there because he
was part of the Rocks crew at that time
and so I think that there's a very good
chance that we could see Garling
attacking Whitebeard when rocks does
eventually attack the island and man if
Garling is giving Whitebeard scars then
this man is going to be no joke and
should be a devastatingly powerful
fighter like I for one would give
anything to see a full out fight between
these two and fingers crossed that we're
going to get more of that however since
we're talking about rocks this brings up
the next really interesting point here
because you have to keep in mind that we
were told by singu that the Rocks
Pirates attacked God Valley and were
only defeated by the combined powers of
Roger and the hero of the Marines GARP
but now I'm actually wondering how much
of that is actually true if any because
now that we know that God Valley wasn't
just the home of the celestial dragons
who were innocently attacked by rocks we
just have to ask why did rocks attack
God Valley in the first place was he
trying to free the slaves or was this
tournament with so many of the gooa in
one place just the perfect opportunity
for rocks to wipe out the world Nobles
to be honest both do seem quite
reasonable as options but why then would
Roger join the fight to stop rocks like
surely Roger would have hated the
celestial dragons as well for what they
were doing there and he wouldn't have
stopped them from freeing the slav so it
has to be something else here right well
there was actually one other thing that
we were told from this chapter which was
that God Valley was home to some very
valuable natural resources now we
weren't told yet what that resource was
it could be the incredibly rare sea
stone or maybe gold or Emerald the
Emerald City or another incredibly fun
option is from chapter 434 and the same
conversation between Whitebeard and
Shanks where shank says that he brought
some of whitebeard's favorite wine from
his hometown in the West Blue which is
basically now confirmed to be God Valley
but interestingly enough Shanks also
calls this wine medicinal water or
basically healing water so what if God
Valley is a place where magical water
naturally appears definitely seems like
a solid option because right after
drinking the sake or wine Whitebeard
gets up and clashes with Shanks so it
does seem like some pretty good healing
water if you ask me but that's not even
the most interesting option in my
opinion because God Valley might
straight up have been the original home
of devil fruits think about it we've
already speculated in a lot of past
videos that rocks attack God Valley in
order to take a powerful devil fruit SL
devil fruits but I think this whole
situation both supports and also
somewhat opposes this Theory as well
because first off if there were these
powerful devil fruits that were created
here then why wouldn't the world
government or some other super powerful
force come and take them before that
they don't seem to have too much trouble
taking over the kingdom for this
tournament so why not in the past so
that's one point against this idea on
the other hand we do know that kaido
only got his devil fruit after the
battle on God Valley and at the same
time could also be true for Whitebeard
who as far as we know didn't have his
fruit before that battle as well plus
after this chapter we do know of at
least one more character who could have
gotten their overpowered devil fruits
during the battle at God Valley as well
but then again maybe it's just just
because the world nobles were feeding
devil fruits to their slaves for
entertainment so maybe it was to make
that sick kind of hunt more entertaining
and then the people died and they got
the revived devil fruits I mean it's
kind of messed up no matter how you
think about it but the person I was
talking about here was of course Kuma
who might have found his very broken
pawpaw fruit after he was released on
this island with a bunch of other slaves
in order to be hunted down by the
celestial dragons and like wow if if
anyone predicted this sort of twist then
I hereby name you the king of One Piece
theories because I for one never saw
that twist coming like from anywhere and
for Kuma really again this is just a
start of the incredible reveals that we
keep getting and I mean I feel like I
keep saying that I'm like a broken
record at this point but was this really
all just in one single chapter okay
anyways first off we learned that Kuma
is from a race of people called the
Buccaneers now if you're not familiar
this is a term used to describe Pirates
Who mostly attacked Spanish colonies in
North America during the 17th century
which to me means that this race was
likely connected to the ancient Kingdom
who were almost definitely something
like Pirates we also learned that this
race is a mix of humans and giant blood
which is how Kuma came to have their
ridiculous size and strength at least
compared to a regular human and now I'm
actually kind of wondering if this is
also true for some of the other
freakishly tall humans that we've seen
all throughout the story like big mom
and Whitebeard but to further support
this idea that the bakaran were allies
of the ancient kingdoms we're told that
the legend of sangod Nika is actually
passed down through the buccaneer
members and that Kuma even knew both the
name and the same except drum rhythm
that Na's heartbeat makes as well so
could this be why Kuma was so determined
to help Luffy back on sabaot when he
both saved the crew from kizaru and
protected the ship during the time skip
but again that was the connection to
dragon as well so who knows and this
chapter is just insane and we aren't
even done yet because once the world
government learned the truth about
Kuma's family and his race his entire
family was enslaved and taken to marijua
which of course led to Kuma's father and
mother's death and Kuma's eventually
being thrown into the slave hunting
tournament on God Valley and you know
since iankov was there as well maybe
Dragon actually was part of the Marines
came with GARP or something saw what
happened there and then thought oh I'm
going to start the who knows I feel like
it's also interesting and so this might
have actually not have been the worst
thing for Kuma then because this is
where we see him eventually meeting up
with the future revolutionary Army
members Ivanov and a brand new character
named Jenny and yeah okay let's take a
deep breath here because we can
speculate so much more from this like
again as I mentioned this moment right
here could very well be the origin of
the Revolutionary Army which again means
that Dragon might also be showing up on
G Valley very soon just yeah let's let's
keep pouring more gas on onto this
chaotic fire here however I for one am
super curious about jinny here and the
insane possibility that she could be
Luffy's mom not crocodile or is Jenny
crocodile oh my God okay okay I mean you
might be thinking I'm crazy here but
look she's literally eating some meat
and if that's not solid evidence that
this is Luffy's Mom I don't know what is
no man my head's going to explore right
now like no if this is Luffy's mom we
probably won't be seeing her for very
long since mom's pretty much never
survive Back stories but I think Oda
said that I think Luffy's mom is still
alive so and we have seen her in the
story so again maybe it is crocodile
Croc mom SL jinny Ivanov was there oh my
God makes so much makes why does this
make so much sense okay moving on though
if Kuma did indeed find his devil fruit
on this island then his ability to push
people across the world would be the
perfect way for them to eventually
escape the allout war that is coming to
the island very soon and before we now
completely dive off into the deep end of
the pool here though there is even more
to discuss because while we brought up
garlings presence on the islands there
is one piece to all of that that is just
incredibly strange and that's because we
were told that Roger picked up baby
Shanks from a treasure chest and so if
this wasn't actually garlin's home then
why was Shanks here was shang's mom also
here or did Garling just have Shanks
with him did Roger just randomly steal
some treasure and Shang just happen to
be in the chest like UTA in film Rett or
did someone like GARP find Shanks and
give to Roger for protection which would
of course be fitting since it's the
exact inverse of when Roger asks Garb to
look out for Ace after he turned himself
into the Marines and this could
completely change how we think of Shanks
in general because his future role in
the story is like now completely thrown
into like the unknown and even his
mysterious meeting with the G say and if
you want to know everything about the
story of Shang so far you can watch that
video right here Shanks for watching and
I will see you in the next video